so after heckling joe biden during
tuesday night's state of the union
address uh yelling out when joe biden
was literally talking about his son that
died lauren bobert yelling out
in the aftermath of that
she sort of like got a hero's welcome in
a lot of different places and she was
interviewed by turning point usa's
charlie kirk now if you don't know
charlie kirk and you don't know turning
point i envy you but in all seriousness
it's a very well-funded organization
that is pulling in young people to
radical right ideology and they do it
very very effectively charlie kirk
interviewed lauren bober and she
defended her actions saying listen i was
very caught up in the emotion because i
am so worried about the troops that died
under joe biden take a look and so i
think you wore a drill baby drill shirt
as well um yesterday and a lot of the
state of the union is theater so now i
got to ask you congresswoman because
we've been receiving a lot of emails and
some of our listeners are divided um i
think you could probably see part of why
they're divided because we really went
after nancy pelosi when she tore the
speech we said have some respect for the
president what do you have to say for
people that say hey look i'm with you
congresswoman but maybe you shouldn't
interrupt the president at the state of
the union what's your thought on that
uh first of all i you know i was really
caught up in the emotions of it uh right
so first so right off the bat she
basically is is saying it's like a moral
get out of jail free card it was it was
a moment of passion it's sort of like
you killed someone well it was a crime
of passion i wasn't thinking she was so
caught up in the emotion that that's
supposed to be like a blanket
exculpation for what she did mentioning
uh afghanistan but didn't bother to
mention the 13 soldiers uh he went on to
something totally different and uh
totally different yeah his dead son
totally different really just
overwhelmed me and i couldn't help but
speak out and look i would love to have
a conversation in a better setting with
him right and and the way to get such a
conversation is by heckling him when he
talks about his son who died and that's
you know uh kyle rittenhouse the other
day
he said on some show we're gonna we
might sue joe biden he might get a
letter it's like oh we're lee why well
he's like yeah well i asked him to meet
with me five times and he didn't and
it's the same type of uh of idea here
she would like to meet with joe biden
but joe biden hasn't met with her so she
heckled them while he was talking about
dead soldiers and his son who died and
and now he's going to meet with you i i
would love to be able to talk to him and
maybe i'll get the chance to do that
when republicans are in the majority in
uh 2023 and we can actually put forward
my articles of impeachment for joe biden
and have a real conversation yeah uh
you're not gonna you're also not gonna
have a conversation with joe biden if
you put forward your silly articles of
impeachment which she and marjorie
taylor green have been talking about now
for months and as far as the drill baby
drill uh goes joe biden he waged a war
on american energy and left us in a very
dangerous place we rely on russian
energy importing nearly 600 000 barrels
of energy per day now i want to talk
about this a little bit
a very popular talking point has become
we were energy independent under joe
biden and now we are not
the data is widely available we cited it
in our story about energy independence a
couple weeks ago for the last several
years the u.s
production of oil
has matched u.s consumption of oil now
you have to understand that
under biden and under trump even though
that's the case there is still trading
going on
and
we send some oil abroad and also bring
some oil in but in terms of the numbers
for several years now we've produced as
much oil as we've consumed so the idea
that joe biden has done any drastic
thing where now we are not at that same
equivalent level of production and uh
use is just a lie and she keeps
repeating it
no one challenges it it's not true when
we should be energy independent and
certainly okay energy dominant we should
be able to export energy to our allies
which is literally exporting freedom and
uh so i i wore drill baby drill on my
shaw to remind the democrats of exactly
what we should be doing yeah no one
cares about that and how we should stop
funding russia's war yeah and that's
that's a lot of the state of the union
is kind of like making
alternative points and i think people
understand that and i'll be honest like
if i was in the audience i don't know if
i would have been able to contain myself
so i think that's a that's a fair answer
if i had to listen to joe biden go on
and yep charlie kirk would have done the
same thing so there's this soft defense
of the completely indefensible and
they're they're not going to stop
they're going to continue doing it and
we're it
unless these folks are just removed or
forced to behave differently
they will continue escalating and it's
not going to change and that shouldn't
surprise anybody
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees uh i like the cooler option i
keep mine at 60 degrees and it gives me
a great cool night of sleep no feeling
hot no more sweating i'm falling asleep
faster and it pairs perfectly with chili
sleeps weighted chili blanket which
keeps you cold on top too and for a
limited time chili sleep has a special
offer just for my audience go to
chillysleep.com
pacman to learn about the exclusive
discount the link is down below